this is sean mellier and he's what's
known as an
ethical hacker he helps companies
tighten up their cyber security
and he knows a lot about hacking don't
sue me microsoft
today he's going to be breaking down the
hacking mechanics of some of our
favorite games to tell us how realistic
or unrealistic they really are whoever
designed the system
probably needs to be fired let us know
in the comments below if there are any
other games you want sean to break down
and make sure to subscribe for more
videos like this and check out our other
reaction
videos in the description of this video
so without further ado
take it away sean
a big jump
preach protocol code matrix sequence
required template okay
you just have to match a few characters
um i guess we'll pause really quick
that looks looks fun i mean it looks
technical since you're like looking at
little characters and stuff and putting
them in a sequence but
i don't think that equated to to
anything breach photocall sounds cool i
like that i wish we used that like in
our
daily thing like i might start just
throwing it around there and see see if
it sticks you know but
um i i've never used the phrase breach
protocol
ever until right now
it's it's cool to like show in the
aspect that you gotta like solve a quick
little puzzle to get in
and stuff like that i'm not sure about
all the context with it but protocol is
basically like a way for
devices to communicate between each
other so you have to like
know the correct language to speak to
these different protocols so if every
everything uses the same one then it's
then it's a lot easier
but if you have different devices using
different ones then it can get kind of
more hairy and then you have to do
more research if a hacker has enough
time they're going to find their way in
if they have enough resources they're
going to find their way in if this is my
understanding
the breach protocol thing if that's what
everyone uses for all their enhancements
and stuff like that
then you might be able to come up with
like i broke the broke the
you know the handshake or whatever and i
can like connect to anything or
something like that
you would think the manufacturer or like
whoever owns this
protocol or device would like come up
with like a fix pretty quickly if they
realize that this was broken
but i mean then you have to also update
all these devices that are in people's
bodies like if it's in their eyes or
their
wherever then you gotta like force an
update to all that so i don't know it
becomes a huge thing like if you're
putting some
something in your body that needs to be
updated that just
scares me it's got a buffer i guess
they're trying to make it so like you
overflow the buffer but you're not i
don't know
let's say like that breach protocol like
login thing um where he's trying to hack
into it
is more or less like an admin interface
you can sometimes like
send payloads to different fields that
would bypass authentication
sending it something that it can't
really process correctly and that's
that's what a lot of hacking is honestly
is like
you play around with something you get
familiar with it and then you say like i
want to see if i can get
to get it to do x y or z and then you
kind of like play around with different
functionality until you can kind of get
there
you would think like if this kept
happening to people
like that their eyes kept getting
short-circuited you would think that
they would like take that out or figure
out a way to patch it or
you know prevent this from happening you
would think people would like be
having an uprising if somebody could
like like blow up their eyeball or
something like that or turn it off or
something um
but that's just that's just my take
i'm assuming he's using his phone to
hack these cars i don't know what year
this takes place in but the fact that
all these cars are connected to the
internet or
have some type of self-driving software
that you can hack or something like that
the fact that they're all probably using
different technology
having one device that could make all
these cars go forward
um and crash and do stuff like that
unlikely i think you'd be safe from
somebody doing that
i mean this is some nice tech i'm not
gonna lie
we can hit pause there it doesn't really
show you what this spot did
but in a lot of terms if you get
physical access to a device
it's kind of game over in a lot of sense
if you do get access to something
like likelihood of you being able to
break it and hack it and stuff like that
is very high if it was
a device that they had developed an
exploit for then that
totally could happen but if this can
happen throughout the game to any device
that comes up
then i would say that's a little more
unlikely
i guess he downloaded that access keys
downloading data from
these cameras i would say the likelihood
that these cameras can
do all this stuff is unlikely i don't
know what these cameras have in them but
it's not typical for for a security
camera to do that
they really take a lot of liberty with
with the hacking in
this game i will say another thing with
like security cameras
a lot of times you'll see like companies
that have like cameras exposed to the
internet
deployed with default credentials of
admin ad
like username admin password admin
username admin password12345 something
like that so
in a lot of cases people don't change
these credentials so
what can happen here is like when the
little robot
got access to the physical device it
might have been able to log in with like
default credentials
the likelihood that the cameras that
connected to the security system are
able to interact with
other devices like a smart tablet and
download information back to the camera
and then back to the hacker
very very unlikely i don't want to say
anything's impossible because when it
comes to hackers when you say
something's impossible or they can't do
it they always
find a way to like to do it i wouldn't
be able to do that i don't know anyone
that would be able to do that um
but there might be somebody out there
who knows
yeah i mean this is like docs on
steroids
if you've ever heard of like doxxing
someone where you get all their
information and you compile it and stuff
like that
yeah this is a lot of information to get
like and all their
associates information as well if you're
able to find this information
out about anyone with their phones or
anything like that all hell would break
loose i feel like
to figure out all this information they
would have to have some exploit that
worked on every phone
um unless there's some funds that you
can't get into like secure phones or
something like that but
i feel like uh tim cook would like to
know about this or
uh somebody i'm gonna go with
on not not likely
got it
[Music]
is wait is this him cracking the
password or is this just the screen
oh
there we go okay all right i guess we'll
just pause it really quick
so if on here it looks like it's like
doing like a hex dump but i don't know
any system
that would ever on a login page start
dumping out the password
in like little chunks or whatever on the
screen for you to figure out but
real password cracking you get access to
like the hashes
um that are stored like in a database or
on the computer or system
and then pulling them off and then
either through brute force
or through like like a password list or
different permutations and doing
different things like adding exclamation
points to the common words or whatever
it is
looking at uh previous breaches from
like let's say like myspace or
linkedin and figure out like some
password that somebody used for some
other website and then
rehashing that and checking to see if
like that hash matches up and then
you'd be able to like guess the password
i i've never seen a system that on the
login page starts giving you the
password for you to choose that would
just that just seems to
be the purpose of requiring a password
whoever designed the system
probably needs to be fired
max security bots are friendly and will
attack your enemies
okay this just seems like a fun game
um rerouting some liquid i guess would
hack the
spot to make it friendly i don't know if
you got access to the bot
and it rerouting some cables or some
pipes and this
in this case change something and make
it friendly and make it yours then
that might work i guess i would have to
get my hands on it
to see what was going on doesn't seem
too difficult
i guess it gets more difficult the
bigger the puzzle yeah this this isn't
the typical
packing that you'd see this is more like
plumbing
i don't know it looked like a fun game i
don't know it looked like it looked like
a little children's game or something
i'm assuming this map right here is like
pivoting around through some proxies to
get somewhere or something like that i
just want to
pause it on one of these things little
pop-ups that pops up okay
so i'm i'm just freezing it really quick
to look at
the ip address on here these are not
like correct ip addresses like
the max amount you can have in one of
those octets is 255.
they have a 400 dot i think 65.983
this is like kind of classic uh games or
television ip addresses but i guess they
also don't want to provide an
address to something that could actually
be like
an ip address out there in the world and
some people start poking at it it's
really like
some government id address or something
like that
password breaker i mean the fact that
the username is admin is very very
likely
i'm just gonna hit pause really quick i
mean it's not showing any of the actual
hacking it's showing like the password
breaking but the fact that the username
was admin
nine times out of ten it is gonna be it
is going to be admin the way they were
able to pull the password out you could
do that with like a time-based sql
injection where it kind of like
determines the next character like in a
string for you
they're not showing any of that
technical stuff but that could be
happening in the background and you can
actually use
tools or scripts that can automate all
that for you as of right now this is
probably the closest to real hacking
that out of any of the clips that we've
seen where it's the most believable to
me
okay got a terminal open got of course
you got to use telnet you can't use ssh
man
oh so do you actually like type this in
as you're doing it this is kind of cool
that terminal is what you like if you
come across something that's like
connected that's like deals with like uh
cameras and that has like a some type of
like telnet access or ssh or whatever it
is
the interface is kind of funky like that
it's like a lockdown shell where it
lets you put in certain commands
something similar that you could come
across like doing like a
pen test or hacking something i mean
this isn't super like hacking once you
get access to a system and you're logged
in and you're able to like send commands
to something
you already you're already in
is this like a weird sauna prison thing
or something
i'm gonna pause right here to see what's
on the screen so it's aimbot version 2.9
beta so
all the versions before that like 2.8
were just they were not good you know so
how to
make sure we got the 2.9 beta they're
showing something like some
pseudo terminal output that you'd see
like if you typed in like iwlan
or ifconfig or something like that i
love how he has the
post-it notes they clearly have this
like app installed
for namebot and stuff like that but they
needed the post-it notes to uh tell them
how to go up and down
whenever you see post-it notes like
added like at someone's desk i'm always
like
please don't be a password please don't
be a password on there like something
like that
but in a lot of cases like people will
will do that because they're they don't
want to forget their password and have
call id and then do all that stuff
[Music]
i can i just pause really quick just to
look at what's on the screen here sorry
i was trying to take everything in and
then i realized that there's a lot on
the screen to read
this is like great i've never heard of
this game but it's cool say you're
given an ip address that you're supposed
to hack into or find some
vulnerabilities or do whatever i guess
in this case the objective is to
hack into this ip address and delete
some files and stuff like that if you're
just trying to quickly get in and find
stuff out then you kick off some port
scans
80 25 21 and 22 are pretty common ports
but if you're only scanning those you're
probably going to miss out on
some other services or something running
on a non-standard port but i mean this
is a
a pretty common step as far as like pen
testing or hacking goes is running a
type of port scan you want to see what's
what's out there like what what am i
hacking exactly is it just like an ssh
server that i have to like
either brute force a password or find
some password to reuse or find an
explain for
or is it an http server like do they
have are they running a web application
that can have vulnerabilities in it
same with all these other services like
ftp or smtp
you're going to run into the same thing
like am i looking for credential reuse
or weak credentials or
am i going to run some type of exploit
uh-oh i'm getting i guess we're getting
hacked back
oh no blue screen i love how
it's a linux system but then they give
you the like the blue screen of death
which is windows
i think they just do that to like make
you like be like oh no it's crashed like
because everyone thinks blue screen is
synonymous with crash i mean that that
interface and everything like that
typing commands into a terminal and
doing things import scanning
those are all pretty common things that
you do the
only thing that kind of is funky is the
cracking all the services very quickly
there's no version detection they don't
even know what's running they just ran a
program that was able to kind of break
the service and and basically hack it
so the fact that there wasn't any like
version detection to determine what
they're running
to find an exploit that works for that
that
is something that doesn't add up because
a lot of cases to
exploit like a protocol let's say it's
like ssh i don't even know how many
different versions or different
companies that make a different type of
like ssh login you need to have a very
specific exploit for each one
typically especially on later versions
so it the fact that it just worked
out of the box without having to like do
any type of
configuration or anything else is
not believable and if something does
come out like that
that you can just hack into like any ssh
server
it's going to be bad bad news
for a lot of companies thanks so much
for watching i've enjoyed watching these
uh
these hacking clips in the games i hope
to see you all again soon if you have
any games that involve hacking that
you'd like reviewed please feel free to
drop them in the comments below
you